herzlich willkommen zu einer deutschland
am dienstag schön dass sie dabei sind
wegen der aktuellen lage starten wir die
sendung mit einem corona kompakt und
sprechen da gleich auch mit dem
virologen professor schmidt chanasit
zunächst aber da gucken wir erst mal auf
den heutigen tag und die neuesten
entwicklungen im kampf gegen das corona
virus mit dem auto zum arzt nürtingen
hat ein corona abstrich zentrum als
drive-in eingerichtet der andrang ist
enorm
wartezeiten bis zu drei stunden müssen
die menschen einplanen die polizei muss
regelnd eingreifen weil einige
ungeduldige versuchen sich an der
warteschlange vorbei nach vorne zu
drängen
wohlgemerkt es geht hier nur um
verdachtsfälle die zahl der tatsächlich
infizierten und leider auch der an
corona verstorbenen steigt ständig das
robert koch institut habe angesichts der
rapiden ausbreitung der korona
virusinfektion das risiko für die
bevölkerung nun als hoch eingestuft mit
recht denn die zahlen sind alarmierend
nach neuesten angaben gibt es in
deutschland sieben 1689 infizierte 20
menschen sind an den folgen der
viruserkrankung gestorben
zu den maßnahmen um die infektionskette
zu unterbrechen gehört auch die sperrung
der spielplätze unter anderem in
schneverdingen in niedersachsen
doch trotz des verbots schildes spielen
kinder in der sonne sitzen eltern auf
den bänken das verbot wird ignoriert als
sinnlos bezeichnet wenn es das gesetz
jetzt ist und man darf nicht dann müssen
wir uns daran halten aber moment finde
ich doch schon ein bisschen übertrieben
bei dem schönen wetter denke ich lässt
sich das nicht vermeiden dass kinder
zusammenkommen und wir haben eigentlich
geplant bei schönem wetter und viele
stunden draußen zu verbringen und mit
freunden zu treffen auch mit den kindern
dass die draußen sich austoben können
eventuell auch noch mal zum sportplatz
bisschen sport machen man kann sowieso
von der krankheit nicht weglaufen
also ich sehe das so wenn die stunde
abgelaufen ist sie sowieso abgelaufen
was passiert wenn nicht genügend abstand
gehalten wird weiß pastor lothar krauß
aus gefangen niedersachsen gemeinsam mit
seiner frau heike lebte schon seit ende
februar in häuslicher quarantäne
angefangen hat er sich den corona virus
bei einem kongress in baden württemberg
im videochat berichtet er von seinen
erfahrungen einer der referenten der war
er war einfach positiv mit dem kroner
virus bereits infiziert ohne es selbst
zu wissen
und weil er ein student aus alten tagen
von mir ist den ich unterrichtet habe
weil die begrüßen sehr herzlich und wir
haben uns intensiv ausgetauscht und
dabei habe ich dieses geschenk bekommen
dass keine antwort spielplätze gesperrt
geschäfte geschlossen jetzt machen auch
große unternehmen ihre werks tore für
die beschäftigten zu in rüsselsheim
betrifft das opel wie viele leute kennen
denn der arbeiten und die wollen ja muss
ich alle geschäfte und so dass wir
nachgelassen
ja wohl schon einige zugemacht habe auch
bei konkurrent volkswagen schlagen die
folgen der korona virus pandemie durch
seinen größten autobauer der welt soll
an den meisten standorten in deutschland
am freitag die vorerst letzte schicht
laufen und wir gucken jetzt nach hamburg
denn da ist uns professor schmidt
chanasit zugeschaltet vom deutschen
zentrum für infektionsforschung ja in
dem beitrag haben wir auch gerade noch
mal gehört dass das robert koch institut
die gesundheitsgefahr für die
bevölkerung in deutschland nicht mehr
nur als mäßig einschätzt sondern jetzt
neu als hoch keine guten nachrichten
oder was bedeutet das ja das war zu
erwarten
die fallzahlen weiter nach oben auch die
todeszahlen werden weiter ansteigen das
ist das was wir vorhergesagt haben und
man muss natürlich die situation die
eben sich stetig entwickelt anpassen und
auch entsprechende maßnahmen ergreife
und das hat das robert koch institut
heute getan
wir sprechen da später auch noch drüber
denn sie sind bei uns heute für corona
kompakt um auch die fragen der zuschauer
zu beantworten dann ist das natürlich
gleich auch noch mal thema plus weitere
fragen also ich sage vielen dank für den
moment und bis gleich ja liebe zuschauer
das große ziel all der aktuellen
einschränkungen und schließungen das
kennen sie das ist es ja das virus zu
bremsen also die zahl der
neuansteckungen so gering zu halten wie
es eben nur
geht und dazu gehören eben auch die
quarantänemaßnahmen was bedeutet das
konkret 14 tage das haus nicht zu
verlassen
und wie kann es sein dass betroffene in
dieser extremsituation sogar noch
angefeindet werden
ein beispiel aus münster hier wird heute
nicht gespielt die julius moses kita in
münster seit zwei wochen herrscht
stillstand
wir mussten vor gut zwei wochen die
einrichtung schließen da eine unserer
kolleginnen positiv auf das corona virus
getestet wurde und unsere kinder und
familien sowie die mitarbeiter der
einrichtung wurden für 14 tage unter
quarantäne gestellt auch ihre tochter
geht in die betroffene kita das kam ganz
plötzlich und hat uns sehr überrascht
wir haben uns auch erschrocken dass es
plötzlich auch so nah ist das ist
natürlich mit vier kindern und jungen
hund und zwei katzen eine ganz schöne
herausforderung und dann die
überraschende wendung schon nach zwei
tagen wird die quarantäne aufgehoben
aber nur für die eltern
wir hatten trotzdem auch bedenken das
haus zu verlassen weil es schon eine auf
ruhe gibt unter den menschen
es wurde mir vorgeworfen dass es
unverantwortlich sei dass man man
arbeiten geht und seine ganze firma auch
in gefahr bringt und ich sollte mir doch
gut überlegen ob ich wirklich auch noch
einkaufen gehen würde und es war neben
diese angst als auch so dass wir auch
nicht schuld sein wollten dass wir
vielleicht doch jemanden anstecken
gründen
die kinder stehen unter quarantäne aber
die eltern dürfen raus das sorgt für
verunsicherung warum diese entscheidung
wir fragen nach beim gesundheitsamt
münster für die haushaltsgemeinschaft
erkrankter kinder oder erzieherinnen
gelten die strengen regelungen der
kategorie eins weil durch die engen
kontakte die ansteckungsgefahr besonders
hoch ist
bei den übrigen kindern und
erzieherinnen oder hausbewohnern gelten
wegen der weniger engen kontakte die
allgemeinen empfehlungen zur hygiene
kontakt reduktion und wachsamkeit ob
symptome auftreten
im klartext laut gesundheitsamt müssen
nur die menschen in quarantäne die einen
direkten kontakt zu einer infizierten
person hatten quarantäne oder gar eine
infektion die vorstellung sorgt bei
vielen für verunsicherung und oft stecke
die sorge in wut um hier wird der ärger
gegen die ad ihren rausgelassen in den
sozialen medien
so etwas sollte bestraft werden wir
müssen definitiv die kosten mittragen
[Musik]
ausfindig machen und ihr die gerechte
strafe geben wie fahrlässig domann sein
kann aber auf kinder loslassen
halleluja manche kommentare habe mich
wirklich schockiert
einfach weil ich nicht nachvollziehen
kann wie man über eine situation und
besonders auch über eine person urteilen
kann ohne die genauen hintergründe zu
kennen unsere kollegin hat absolut
richtig absolute verantwortungsbewusst
gehandelt
sie würde niemals absichtlich das risiko
eingehen jemanden anzustecken und solche
kommentare zu lesen das macht schon
ärgerlich
die suche nach einem sündenbock sie hat
begonnen experten überrascht das nicht
an führt dann schnell zu
schuldzuweisungen wenn ich nicht den
aggressor wirklich angreifen kann also
den virus kann ich selber nicht
angreifen der ist einfach da und deshalb
versuche ich ersatz formen zu finden
oder auch ersatz personen oder auch
ersatz gegenstände von den eindruck habe
die können meine wut gegen den virus
sind irgendeiner form kanalisieren mein
mann und ich wir haben gemeinsam
überlegt ob überhaupt dieses interview
machen freuen und das hat den einfachen
grund
da wir nicht abschätzen können wie die
menschen darauf reagieren ja und für uns
war ganz schnell klar dass das bei uns
zu hause nicht geht weil wir unsere
kinder schützen wollen
vor eventuellen an verhandlungen das
macht uns wirklich sehr betroffen dass
wir uns überhaupt solche gedanken machen
müssen
ich habe keine angst vor dem virus ich
habe angst davor was ist aus dem
menschen macht die kita in münster
bleibt jedenfalls erst mal bis nach
ostern geschlossen weiter hin geöffnet
und das hoffentlich ohne größere
einschränkungen haben die apotheken
neben den arztpraxen sind sie nämlich
die hauptanlaufstelle für kranke und das
bringt einige neue herausforderungen mit
sich und auch risiken denn was passiert
wenn sich das apothekenpersonal selber
mit dem krone virus ansteckt nachschub
für die adler apotheke in moers am
niederrhein vieles geht zur neige denn
die händler geben nur noch bestimmte
kontingente an die apotheken ab auch der
chef simon griff bekommt die ausnahme
situation zu spüren
es herrscht hochbetrieb in seiner
apotheke die nachgefragte menge ist eine
außergewöhnliche situation dass die
mengen die tagtäglich in die apotheke
kommen aber gleichzeitig auch die
apotheke wieder verlassen sind schon 50
prozent höher als im normalfall das
personal hat alle hände voll zu tun denn
sie müssen sich auch um die kunden
kümmern die nicht wegen des krone virus
sondern wegen anderer krankheiten kommen
meine zwei mitarbeiter die sich rund um
die uhr quasi in ihren arbeitszeiten
damit beschäftigen die händler ab zu
telefonieren um die dringend benötigten
materialien zu beschaffen
denn wir möchten nicht dass am ende mit
chemotherapie nicht gegeben werden kann
oder nicht hergestellt werden kann
nur weil wir nicht die entsprechende
ausrüstung für die herstellung vorrätig
haben weil desinfektionsmittel derzeit
überall schwer zu bekommen sind
produziert die apotheke inzwischen
selber das ist seit anfang märz erlaubt
vier mitarbeiter haben hier in den
vergangenen tagen 800 liter
desinfektionsmittel für die hände
hergestellt aber auch andere dinge
werden knapp lieferengpässe haben wir
natürlich bei aller art von
schutzkleidung mundschutz haben kippe
das wird mittlerweile ein problem damit
hat keiner von uns gerechnet ist auch
für uns kein normalzustand
so zahlt simon krivec inzwischen jeden
preis für ausrüstung und medikamente hat
ein mundschutz vergangenes jahr noch
drei cent gekostet so zahlt er jetzt 70
cent für die beschäftigten bedeutet die
aktuelle lage flexibel sein
die mitarbeiter sollten so wenig kontakt
wie möglich haben um das risiko eine
ansteckung zu reduzieren
wir werden unsere teams jetzt in
kleinere gruppen aufteilen einfach um
sicherzustellen dass wenn ein
mitarbeiter infiziert ist nur ein
kleiner teil der mitarbeiter in
quarantäne muss und wir unseren betrieb
offen halten können
das alles sei aber derzeit noch zu
bewerkstelligen so krivec denn alle
ziehen mit grund zur panik gebe es nicht
die versorgung sei sicher gestellt auch
wenn man vielleicht mal etwas länger
warten muss auch in der apotheke
aber das sollte ein vergleichsweise
kleines problem sein in diesen mehr als
herausfordernden tagen denke ich mal ein
bisschen mehr zeit gehört leider einfach
dazu und über diese herausforderung die
wir gerade alle gemeinsam bewältigen
müssen und tun darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit professor jonas schmidt chanasit vom
deutschen zentrum für
infektionsforschung wir haben eben schon
mal kurz gesprochen
sie sind virologe und ihr
forschungsbereich sind neu auftretender
infektionskrankheiten also im grunde
genau das worum es gerade weltweit geht
aber hätten sie persönlich jemals
gedacht dass es einmal soweit kommen
kann dass ein virus die welt mehr oder
weniger so zum stillstand bringt dass
das theoretisch möglich ist war uns
natürlich allen klar wir haben viele
ausbrüche direkt miterlebt ebola lassa
dengue ca die hatten bei weitem nicht
diese auswirkungen wie der ausbruch des
neuen chores insofern ist für mich das
auch neuland und wir lernen tagtäglich
dazu was haben sie bisher am meisten
gelernt dass pressearbeit ganz schön
anstrengend sein kann
aber sie sagen es mit einem lächeln und
vielen dank dafür denn sie ist ja auch
sehr sehr wichtig in diesen tagen
deswegen stellen sie sich ja auch den
fragen unserer zuschauern aus dem
youtube kanal und er hat krim befragt
crm kann man sich über kleine wunden auf
der haut bzw an den händen anstecken und
kann man sich mehrfach anstecken
nein das ist nicht der typische
übertragungsweg der typische
übertragungsweg ist eben über tröpfchen
die man letztendlich in den mund bekommt
oder eben in die augen
eine andere übertragung ist sehr
unwahrscheinlich und auch die infektion
in kurzer zeit sind unwahrscheinlich
oder ausgeschlossen
alle gehen davon aus dass zumindest für
einen gewissen zeitraum einige immunität
besteht von mehreren monaten oder jahren
wie oskar hat uns auch geschrieben er
fragt warum unterscheidet sich die zahl
der infizierten und diese todesfälle in
den ländern so stark voneinander das
geht jetzt wirklich weit auseinander
ja das sind dramatische unterschiede da
wir sehen ganz entscheidende faktoren
sind wie die länder reagiert haben ob
sie sehr sehr viel testen sowie südkorea
ob eine schnelle und gute behandlung der
kranken möglich ist und inwieweit sie
eben ihre gefährdeten personen also
älter oder patienten mit vorerkrankungen
schützen
das sind die entscheidenden faktoren und
je besser man das macht desto geringer
als die sterblichkeit heißt das jetzt
bei dem im verhältnis zu anderen ländern
noch relativ gering todeszahlen dass das
bisher ganz gut geklappt hat in
deutschland ja ja das muss man definitiv
sagen sie sehen ja wir haben ja den
webasto cluster in münchen frühzeitig
erkannt sie können sich vorstellen wenn
das nicht diagnostiziert und aufgedeckt
worden wäre was dann passiert wäre das
hätte sich still sehr weit verbreitet in
münchen und dann wären wir heute an
einem ganz anderen punkt da sehen sie
wie gut das funktioniert in deutschland
kommt noch mal zurück auf die
pressearbeit wo sie das jetzt ganz so
klar gesagt haben das heißt wenn man das
jetzt noch mal größer auch noch mal
thematisiert dass wir bisher nur so
verhältnismäßig wenige todesfälle haben
zeigt einfach dass vieles gut gemacht
ist und könnte ja auch dem auftrieb
geben für die maßnahmen dass die
menschen wissen mensch es macht sinn
sich jetzt so abzugrenzen
ja natürlich also das haben wir auch
immer wieder betont dass es ganz wichtig
ist dass jeder mithilft und nochmal das
ist eine momentaufnahme
es kann sich ändern es kann viel
schlimmer werden und umso wichtiger ist
es dass wir jetzt alle eben genau das
befolgen was letztendlich das robert
koch institut und das
gesundheitsministerium auch empfehlen
und diese maßnahmen alle gemeinsam
umsetzen
wir danken für die informationen die sie
uns gegeben haben vielen dank für die
antworten professor schmidt chanasit
und wenn sie weitere fragen haben an
unsere experten dann schicken sie uns
einfach eine mail an corinna kompakt
zdf.de wir beantworten die dann gerne so
gut es geht